What are your thoughts on leotro? That'd be a good thing to add for breast cancer
would be best to add the apricot seed form or the supplement form. So yes, I'm
big fan of leotro. So you could get the seed form. That's this is the seeds. And
people can just eat these seeds. They look like almonds. They taste like poison.
So I'm not a fan of these things. I could just about eat anything but these
taste horrible. So and I'm not so sure how good it is for your teeth. So we have
these on sale in the store because some people like, no, I've used to them. I
really like them. And so we do have these at our store. Typically if we test
to cheek swab test and we test, we find that B17 slash a big deal in the
slash leotro is good for somebody that we use the capsule form. This is the
capsule form that is just the B17 component. It's not the entire seed. And it
comes in 500 milligram or 100 milligram capsules. And if depending on what I
recommended for you, make sure you purchase the right thing. 500 milligram
capsules is five times the 100 milligram capsules. And you don't want to be
taking too much of something if that's what you're doing. So just make sure you're
aware of that. We have a big grab letters on the store so it shouldn't make that
distinct. But if you're just like, you know, I've never been tested for me. I just
feel like I want to take it. You can take this thing, this product right here. This
product is the entire seed itself that's just ground and encapsulated. So it only
has 60 milligrams of the B17 in it. But from a whole food perspective, it can be
better in ways. It has the B15 that's also included in the apricot seed itself. So
if you're just like, Hey, I just want to start taking it. I feel like to take that then maybe
you consider this. We have all these in the store. This would be more of a whole food
type product. But if you're like trying to get 500 milligrams of B17 in you, it's really
hard to do that. You're taking a lot of pills of this. So it's better to take just one
of the 500 milligrams. So some people are taking three of the 500 milligrams. You're
taking 1500 milligrams. Good as sex would be taking a ton of these and that would get
a costly for them. So those are your choices for a B17.